little Gary
struggled in school but he did not
struggle when he sold lemonade or when
he rang doorbells to wash cars so let me
tell you kids about entrepreneurship the
number one cool thing about your school
and the number one cool thing on the
journey that you're on everyone says no
that this idea is not going to work
your parents your teachers the people
that you must listen to the most but
when it comes to entrepreneurship
even if they don't think it's a good
idea and you think it's a good idea you
must try it
it might not work and many of my ideas
did not work many of my businesses did
not work
but as entrepreneurs like all of us are
it's almost like our destiny to try to
make the things and the ideas that we
have to happen
so Gary I'm just gonna briefly introduce
you I'm going to hand it over to Laura
she's going to really introduce you give
it back to you you're going to talk
first why you're really excited to be
here and then the kids have questions
for you cool
guys this is a really big deal so Gary
it just hosted about 10 000 people this
weekend by the way I've been an
entrepreneur for a very long time and
all entrepreneurs need mentors and I'm
lucky enough to be able to call Gary a
mentor of mine there's very few people
in the world that are as caring and
compassionate as Gary who cares so much
about soft skills like you're learning
with the seven mindsets
um and cares so much about really
bringing these stories to life through
his nft collection and you understand
nfts which is so awesome because you're
getting one uh and so I'm just so
excited to have him and Laura you can
kind of talk about why you're so excited
that Gary's here all right so welcome
garyvee we're super excited to unhappy
with us today
um kids this is garyvee garyvee
they've been learning about uh
themselves and how they learn through
their levels of Engagement through their
different mindsets and so much of it
aligns with what you always talk about
with what's important in life and that's
what they're learning at a young age and
so we're really excited for them to be
able to ask you some questions today so
um first up Hello my name is
and my question and my question is how
did you become an entrepreneur
thank you so much
um first of all class I'm so excited to
be with all of you this is the highlight
of my day I'm so so happy and I'm
excited to answer your questions
um you know I don't think I I don't
think I became an entrepreneur I think I
was born an entrepreneur
for everyone who's sitting in class by
the time I was in second and third grade
I was already really excited for the
summer to sell lemonade
I liked to like hang out with my friends
and create like a little yep get on me
with that for selling lemonade
um I uh you know I liked creating like
little stores with my friends you know I
would go door to you know in the 1980s
kids kids would just go outside and we
would just bring people's doorbells and
try to sell them flowers
um so I I think for a lot of you you
just love music you just love cooking
you just love school I feel like a lot
of people are born with things that they
love and I loved being a business mind
and a business kid and a businessman
and then but here's what's important
kids a lot of you love certain things
skateboarding rock climbing
you know
um drawing coloring making music making
videos being a good friend but the key
is to practice
right just because you're born good at
something if you don't practice and
practice and practice and practice and
practice
then you may not be able to achieve the
highest levels of what you're trying to
achieve and so Not only was I born a
businessman or an entrepreneur
but starting around your age up until
right now
I've been practicing almost every day at
it which is what's made me good at it
not just liking it
um hi my name is my question is where do
you get your inspiration from
first of all thank you for your question
that's a great question before you go
away can I ask you a question
where where do you get your inspiration
from
hello
very nice so for me my inspiration comes
from my parents
I was not born in America I was born in
the Soviet Union which is now Russia and
Belarus and some countries maybe you
haven't heard of yet but you know we
came to America and we had very little
we were immigrants
and I lived in a small apartment with a
lot of not only my parents but my
grandparents my great-grandparents my
uncle and so it was very humble
beginnings and so my parents loved me so
much and worked so hard and they gave me
the opportunity so I'm filled with
gratitude for my parents and they're my
inspiration
can relate to that that like your
parents are your number one supporters
all right
hi my name is
and my question is how did you get
through school
that's a good question
I am I love you for that question I'll
tell you why kids some people School
comes natural just like we talked about
earlier with skateboarding or cooking or
business for me school did not come
natural it was hard
and you know I I struggled in school a
lot of different times
um you were all so lucky because we live
in a world now that understands the
brain better the way kids learn better
the way we all do it differently
um and so the way I got through it was
you know patience
you know uh the way I got through it was
looking for different things that
brought me joy
you know and so I loved math class I
loved history class
I love Jim recess was the best
I loved lunch
and so you know I found different ways
to get through it through the years but
you know I can tell you this one thing
now that I'm done with it I would pay a
lot of money to be back in school and be
able to enjoy my friends and learning
and so you should all really enjoy this
special 12 15 years that you have
because there's nothing like a childhood
and being in school with each other
my name is
and my question is
how did you feel on your first day of
your business and why
that's a great question it's really
interesting that you asked me that
with the question that was just asked
for me
my first day in business officially was
right after I was done with college and
it was in my dad's wine store and don't
forget kids you can't drink wine until
you're 21. but it was my in my uh in
fair enough
um and so it was my dad's wine store and
I had been working in it since I was 14
and I loved it there I loved helping my
dad
so the way I felt my first day was I was
ecstatic I was thrilled because I
couldn't wait to work for my family's
business and now I was done with school
and I was ready to work it was one of
the best days of my life and the reason
was because I was going to be doing what
I was born to do which is to be a
businessman
hi my name's I am and my question is are
you happy with your life that's a great
question
thank you uh I'm extremely happy with my
life kids
you may remember this you might not
because I know how young you are but
even if one of you remembers exactly
what I'm about to say for the rest of
your life then this is one of the best
meetings I've ever had in my life
because it means you're going to start
believing this very early I'm extremely
happy with my life
because I'm thankful for everything I
have and I have no Envy or jealousy or
wants or needs of what other people want
kids one of the biggest issues in the
world is people are jealous or envious
of other people they want what they have
they want the kind of things they have
maybe it's the book bag they have the
clothes they have the money they have
the house they have the toys they have
and this goes on forever when you get
older the reason I'm so happy with my
life is because I never worry about
other people I actually only root for
other people I want other people to have
those things I'm happy that they have
those things I hope that they're happy
too but by keeping my life very simple
and just being grateful for what I have
being grateful for what I have makes me
the happiest I'm one of the happiest
people on earth I really believe that
and that's because I keep things simple
as long as I have happiness and health
of my family I don't need things I don't
need things I don't focus on things and
so my life is incredibly happy I'm very
grateful for what I have and I don't
spend time worrying about what I don't
have
right
hi um and my question is why did you
make these sense
great question
why did I make defense
here's why
I
could tell you a lot of good things
right now but I have a feeling if
respectful raccoon did it in a cartoon
or a video game you might understand it
even more
I could tell you about a lot of ways of
how to become likable and why you should
always love your fellow student and
neighbor and teacher but I think likable
leopard has a better chance of getting
you to pay attention to that than I sang
it to you
I created V friends because I really
believe in kindness and love and good
and having compassion and being an
empathetic person and having an attitude
of gratitude
but I know that I'm
only one human being and if I want to
get people to hear the message I have to
do a lot of different things if I want
to explain to you that resilience and
willpower and working hard matters
I have a feeling that the willful wizard
is cooler to you than I am and so I want
to make sure that I leave the biggest
impact of happiness and love on the
world and I need my V friends to help me
do that does that make sense
all right thank you all right uh
hi my name is
and my question is have you spoken in
any schools before
that's a great question
I love your shirt
um
yes I have it's one of my favorite
things to do
um speaking to Children's a lot of fun
because a lot of you are still making
your decisions and learning about
yourself
and for me that's a great time to talk
to kids because then you can really
impact them I remember School assemblies
today and I'm 47 years old and I
remember School assemblies in first
grade third grade fifth grade that had
an impact on me and so I'm very very
honored I'm so grateful that you allowed
me to be with the class is today and so
I have and I will continue and one of
the reasons I created V friends is I
think one of the biggest things you
could ever do is to impact kids and I'm
focused on that
hi I'm
in my question
is how do you draw
the characters
that's a good one thank you for the
question
so
starting around your age everyone I
started to doodle
sometimes in class
and sometimes my teachers were not happy
I was doing that so make sure you pay
attention to your teachers but
sometimes I would doodle on the bus and
after school and I would always doodle
like I really like doodling how many
people here like to draw
so this is interesting kids you'll find
this interesting almost the entire class
raised their hand
almost so many hands just went up but by
the time you're in seventh grade ninth
grade 11th grade a lot a lot of you will
no longer raise your hand and say that
you like to draw a lot of you will stop
drawing I never stop drawing
I never stop doodling and so when it
came time to do V friends
instead of hiring somebody else to do it
I did it and it was one of the most
joyous and fulfilling things I ever did
so if I tell any of you
all of you never stop drawing it's very
creative and it will bring a lot of joy
in your life we have two questions
and his question is
um how did you go from drawing
characters to having them be animated
that's a great question so once I drew
them
now I had them established so then I
worked with a company that created the
second version of them like the way you
see them now versus my drawing
and I've met with a lot of different
companies and I picked the ones that I
thought were the nicest and the people
that could do a good job so sometimes
kids when you get older
and you're in the Work World you'll end
up having Partnerships and make sure
that you remember this it's not just
someone who's good at it it's someone
who you also want to work with because
you'll have a nice relationship
um the last question we have is we
his question is how do you solve
problems
my favorite way to solve problems is to
try to understand
what the other party or person is
thinking about
so how many hey kids real quick by show
of hands or the move how many of you
have had
disagreements with fellow classmates in
your life
thank you
so what we saw right there is
disagreements are a part of life right
even though you might be friendly with
somebody in here you might not see eye
to eye on everything and that's okay
well you have to remember is you can't
just focus on how you feel about it
you have to remember there's another
person too
and you might want to start thinking
about why are they thinking that why do
they see it differently
when I was a kid and somebody would pick
on me or not be nice for some reason
whether it was good Parenting by my mom
or because it was my the way I was born
or probably a combination of both I
would always think they weren't being
mean to me they were in a bad place and
they were unhappy and something must
have been going on in their life and so
they're hurt and so maybe that's showing
up with them not being nice the way I
solve problems is through compassion
and through empathy and trying to
understand what the other person's
problem is and how we solve it and
sometimes that's complicated like a
disagreement or argument and other times
it's just partnering up to make
something happen and you're trying to
understand what they're trying to
achieve so the way I get through these
things is by being curious and asking
questions and always having good intent
for the other person or party Laura can
I ask some questions to Gary absolutely
we have some time great so Gary one of
the skill sets that this CBA is learning
now this is a school all around
entrepreneurship which again is why you
are the most perfect person slash your
little animals for them and they
actually watch v-friends leading up to
this they watch the videos in class
which is so awesome hey kids do you like
did you guys like the be friends videos
Raise Your Hands
all right thank you for the ones
and the ones that did not raise their
hands I'm coming to town to talk to you
about it
one guy's laughing he can he's gonna be
good feedback for you so one of the
skill sets out of the seven skill sets
that they're that you know these
wonderful students are learning is
around learning from failure
and I think that's unbelievable for kids
in a school to really understand that
they can learn from failure so do you
have a story of how you've learned from
failure and what advice do you have
around when something seems like a
failure what can what can we do about it
kids everybody in the world
has failed
there's not a single person that hasn't
failed a lot of times teachers raise
your hands if you failed hundreds of
times in your life
your teachers who are incredible
are human beings who failed in small
ways hundreds of times that's what
happens in life
the quicker you get comfortable with
losing the quicker you're gonna have a
happy life you don't want to lose
it's not necessarily what you're trying
to do but not all losses are really
losses they're just step backs
they're just little moments in time and
they're always an opportunity to learn
and understand and so I highly recommend
you understand that losing is a part of
life
one of the biggest mistakes that
grown-ups sometimes make
is trying to protect kids from losing
losing is a part of life and the quicker
you get comfortable with it
the quicker you're going to have a
happier life
I don't like losing but I know it's a
part and when I lose I try to reflect on
what I could have done better and then I
try to bring that energy to the next
time
so that's what you have to really
realize it's just a part of life just
like the sun coming up and going down
and the moon coming up and going down
you will lose you will get bad grades
you will lose a sporting game like
you'll have a bad day you'll lose a
friend along the way things will happen
and that's okay because you're strong
enough to make it better
so I really like that point one of the
things that we do every month is we give
a staff member the epic failure award uh
next year what I'm hoping is as our kids
get older and they start taking more
risks with their learning that we can
start giving an epic failure or more
intimate kids to celebrate trying
something and coming back for making
money
I I think that is I think the kids are
incredibly lucky that you're doing that
going back to how lucky the kids are uh
I'm going to kind of combine three skill
sets out of the seven Gary because I
know you and I feel like a lot there's
actually probably a character named
after one of these skill sets so in
terms of your life you know the skill
sets around recognizing opportunity
taking risks and staying curious I'm
pretty sure curious is one of your V
friends and you really talk about
curiosity and how it's played a
humongous role in your life and so I'm
curious around how has curiosity brought
you to where you are and how is
curiosity helped you actually find
Opportunities and take risks so how is
that a part of who you are and yeah
which which be friends is it so it is
curious crane which I don't think is in
my office
um
it's when I do this I'm hoping that one
of you hears me
two of you hear me on certain different
things that are valuable to you
this word curiosity is one that I would
love for you to attach on to the Curious
crane which is a bird in my world is a
very important character Amanda's right
Curiosity has been essential in my
happiness why does it work like that why
why why
you know trying different things some of
you if you were asked do you play soccer
actually watch this how many of you here
like soccer raise your hand
s how many people here have never played
soccer or played very little soccer
raise your hands
so for the people that just raised their
hands maybe you do love soccer but you
haven't played yet and instead of being
scared or timid or just not even
considering it doing that for everything
the piano the violin basketball cooking
drawing painting singing karate
you know all these things in the world
that you could be doing if you stay
curious and say maybe instead of no so
many of you say no to things already
how many of you have been asked to do
something with a friend but because you
were scared or you didn't like it you
said no raise your hand
I'm really proud of you for raising your
hand and being honest
what I'm asking the class to do is the
next time a friend asks you to do
something
that you're scared of or you don't think
you like instead of saying no say maybe
and maybe ask them another question
about it
and then half the time say yes and try
it
there are some things that are my
favorite thing to do in the world that I
don't even know because I never did it
it might be surfing it might be pastry
shipping but I never tried it and I want
to do that more in my 40s it's a heck of
a lot better to do it when you're in
your age group so please say maybe and
that's how curiosity works
are you guys on board with that you
understand
yeah
yeah okay uh I would say this is the
last question so you didn't you were not
lucky enough for CBA to exist when you
were a little kid uh so you struggled a
lot with feeling seen and really being
understood within school so if you were
in this audience today you're a little
Gary in the audience right next to
um you know with that really awesome
shirt what do you want to tell yourself
you know again just that you feel like
no one maybe gets you or no one sees you
what do you want to tell that little
Gary in the audience
little Gary
struggled in school but he did not
struggle when he sold lemonade or when
he rang doorbells to wash cars
so let me tell you kids about
entrepreneurship the number one cool
thing about your school and the number
one cool thing on the journey that
you're on is even if everyone says no
that this idea is not going to work
your parents your teachers the people
that you must listen to the most but
when it comes to entrepreneurship
even if they don't think it's a good
idea and you think it's a good idea you
must try it
it might not work
and many of my ideas did not work many
of my businesses did not work
but as entrepreneurs like all of us are
it's almost like our destiny to try to
make the things and the ideas that we
have to happen so I tell you in this
class even though I wasn't lucky enough
to have a class like this or a school
like this
even in this environment that you're in
there will always be people that don't
think your idea is right and they might
be right
but you must try and see your ideas come
into the world
because you'll never live with yourself
if you don't try especially as you get
older class
one day you'll be in the business world
as entrepreneurs and I'm still going to
be doing this
and I cannot wait to work with some of
you in the future and I can't wait for
you to tell me that you were in this
class and so I love you and I can't wait
to see you
thank you